[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight we want to begin tonight's show
with an apology apologies aren't
something you often hear on cable news
on this or any other show but we're
offering one anyway there's no lawsuit
forcing us to do it no court order
making us or skittish advertisers or
sincere in this we mean it it has to do
with Joe Biden Biden as you know is
planning to run for president again he's
been back in the news this week in all
the wrong ways after a series of women
accused him of inappropriate physical
contact
Biden's first accuser Lucy Flores
described what it was like to have the
former vice president kissed the top of
her head I felt him get closer he leaned
in and was like right behind me on my
body and he leans down smells my hair
and then plants this big long kiss on
the top of my head
another accuser woman called a meal a
post remembered that Biden once gave her
an unwelcome Eskimo kiss he walked up to
me and wrapped his hands around my face
like that and pulled me in and started
rubbing noses with me it was for like a
good 15 seconds and I remember thinking
is he gonna kiss me and then yesterday
two more women came forward one of them
accounted that Biden had once hugged her
quote a little too long well this is how
presidential campaigns die so desperate
to end the story Joe Biden released a
statement today promising not to touch
strangers anymore in my career I've
always tried to make a human connection
that's my responsibility I think I shake
hands I hug people I I grab men in lieu
my shoulders is that you can do this now
but it's all about taking selfies
together you know social wars have began
to change they've shifted and the
bombings of protecting personal space
have been reset and I get it
I get it I hear what they're saying I
understand it and I'll be much more
mindful that's my responsibility my
responsibility and I'll mediate but I
always believe governing quite frankly
life for that matter it's about
connecting about connecting with people
that won't change but I will be more
mindful respectful of people's personal
space and that's a good thing there's
something sad pathetic really about
watching a 76 year old man apologize for
not understanding selfie culture you'd
hope your own golden years would be a
little more dignified than that but by
does a politician and he had no choice
they drove him to it and so did we
and that's the point of tonight's
apology when the story first broke that
Biden had been passing out eskimo kisses
and sniffing other people's hair it was
irresistible you couldn't not laugh at
it and we heartily did we mocked Joe
Biden as a compulsive hugger a cuddler
run amuck it was too amusing but we
should have said every bit as loudly and
what we apologize now for not saying is
that hugging is not sexual assault
eskimo kisses aren't rape they used to
be obvious it's not obvious anymore and
so we're sorry for helping to blur the
distinction between human affection and
coercive immoral behavior the last thing
this country needs is more aggrieved
people who think they've been assaulted
because the senior citizen hug them
wrong and so we apologize for adding to
that nonsense and anti human hysteria
none of this by the way is the defense
of Joe Biden the man or his run for
president we disagree with him on a lot
of things just a week ago we told you
about his Craven and absurd claim that
America should get rid of our English
legal tradition Biden says things like
that all the time and we'll keep
criticizing him when he does but hugging
people is not a sin sorry it's not even
if many on the Left would like to
criminalize it well since a Nancy Pelosi
described the lessons she has drawn from
watching Joe Biden I don't think it's
disqualifying because I don't I think it
qualifies with what your intention is I
do think this about communication in
general beyond this I'm a member of the
straight-arm Club I'm you know I'm not
straight
yes pretend you have a cold and I have a
cold let's pretend we all have colds
that's the world Nancy Pelosi demands we
live in but what kind of society is that
a place where everyone has a cold it's a
sick society it's a cold and antiseptic
place a fearful place the society where
censors watch and judge or every action
a place where it's unwise to get too
close to other people in a society like
that exuberance and human warmth are too
risky to display in public
it is a joyless PC hell Nancy Pelosi and
so many on the Left already live there
you can see it on their faces they are
miserable and afraid they insist that we
join them we won't go a country where
you're afraid to touch other people is a
country we don't want to live in